dieser russische pilot stellt sich mutig
gegen putin
schon das wort krieg ist in russland
strengstens verboten wer putins blutige
ukraine invasion nicht sonder operation
nennt dem drohen gefängnisstrafen
doch immer mehr menschen setzen sich
gegen die einseitige berichterstattung
und die anordnungen der kreml propaganda
zu wer in diesem video sehen wir einen
piloten der staatlichen fluggesellschaft
pobeda einer tochterfirma von aeroflot
in seiner lautsprecheransage über das
bordmikrofon spricht er sich klar gegen
den krieg in der ukraine aus auf
russisch und auf englisch
ich denke der krieg mit der ukraine ist
ein verbrechen wir sollten diesen krieg
nicht fortsetzen wir müssen ihnen sofort
beenden denken sie nicht dass dies
russland ist ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
von den passagieren an bord gibt es
applaus offenbar denken viele russen
genau das was der pilot aus spricht sie
wollen nichts mit den gräueltaten von
putin zu tun haben
als angestellte eines staatskonzerns
bringt sich der pilot mit diesen
öffentlichen äußerungen in große gefahr
doch sein video verbreitet sich rasend
schnell in den sozialen medien und damit
auch der wille nach frieden und freiheit
migration